so can I get a show of hands how many of
you in this room have been in the plane
in this past year yeah that's pretty
good well it turns out that you share
that experience with more than three
billion people every year and when we
put so many people in all these metal
tubes that fly all over the world
sometimes things like this can happen
and you get a disease epidemic I first
actually got into this topic when I
heard about the Ebola outbreak last year
and it turns out that although Ebola
spreads through these more range limited
large droplet routes there's all these
other sorts of diseases that could be
spread in the airplane cabin the worst
part is when we take a look at some of
the numbers it's pretty scary
so with h1n1 there was this guy that
decided to go on the plane and in a
matter of a single flight actually
spread disease to 17 other people and
then there's this other guy with SARS
who managed to go on a three-hour flight
and spread the disease to 22 other
people that's not exactly my idea of a
great superpower when we take a look at
this what we also find is that it's very
difficult to pre-screen for these
diseases so when someone actually goes
on the plane there is they could be sick
and they could actually be in this
latency period in which they could
actually have the disease but not
exhibit any symptoms and they could in
turn spread the disease to so many other
people in the cabin and how that
actually works is that right now we've
got air coming in from the top of the
cabin and from the side of the cabin as
you can see in the blue and then also
that air goes out through these very
efficient filters eliminates 99.97% of
pathogens near the outlets and what
happens right now though is that we have
this mixing airflow pattern so if
someone would actually sneeze that air
would get swole around multiple times
before it even has a chance to go out
through the filter so I thought okay
this was clearly a pretty serious
problem and I wasn't I didn't have the
money to go and buy a plane so I decided
to build a computer instead it actually
turns out that with computational fluid
dynamics what we're able to do is create
these simulations that give us higher
resolution
then actually physically going in and
taking in readings in the plane and so
how essentially this works is you would
start out with these 2d drawings these
are floating around in technical papers
around the internet I take that and then
I put it into these 3d modeling software
really building that 3d model and then I
divide that model that I just built into
these tiny pieces
essentially meshing it so that the
computer could better understand it and
then I tell the computer where the air
goes in and out of the cabin throw in a
bunch of physics and basically sit there
and wait until the computer calculates
the simulation so what we get actually
is with the conventional cabin is this
you'll notice the middle person sneezing
and we go splat it goes right into
people's faces it's pretty disgusting
and from the front you'll notice those
two passengers sitting next to the
central passenger not exactly having a
great time and when we take a look at
that from the side you'll also notice
those pathogens spreading across the
length of the cabin first thing that I
thought was this is no good
so I actually conducted more than 32
different simulations and ultimately I
came up with this solution right here
this is what I call a patent-pending
global Inlet director and with us we're
actually able to reduce pathogen
transmission by about fifty five times
and increase fresh air inhalation by
about one hundred ninety percent so how
this actually works is we would install
this piece of composite material into
these existing spots that are already in
the plane so it's very cost effective
install and we can do this directly
overnight all you have to do put a
couple of screws in there and you're
good to go and the results that we get
are actually absolutely amazing instead
of having those problematic swirling
airflow patterns what we have is we can
create these walls of air that come down
in between the passengers to create
these personalized breathing zones so
notice the middle passenger over here is
sneezing again but this time we're able
to effectively push that down to the
filters for eliminations and same thing
from the side you'll notice we're able
to directly push those pathogens down so
if we take a look at again now at the
same scenario but with this innovation
installed you'll notice middle passenger
sneezes and this time we're pushing that
straight down into the outlet before
gets a chance to to infect any other
people so you know this the two
passengers sitting next to the middle
guy all right or breathing virtually no
pathogens at all and we take a look at
that from the side as well you see a
very efficient system and in short with
this system we win so when we take a
look at what this means what we also see
is that this not only works if the
middle passenger sneezes but also if the
window seat passenger sneezes or if the
ILC passenger sneezes and so with this
solution what does that mean for the
world well when we take a look at this
from the computer simulation into real
life we can see with this 3d model dive
built over here essentially using 3d
printing we can see those same airflow
patterns coming down right to the
passengers in the past the SARS epidemic
has actually cost the world about forty
billion dollars and in the future a big
disease outbreak could actually cost the
world in excess of three trillion
dollars so before it used to be that you
had to take an airplane out of service
for one to two months spend tens of
thousands of man-hours several million
dollars to try and change something but
now we're able to install something
essentially overnight and see results
right away so it's really now a matter
of taking this through the certification
flight testing and going through all
these regulatory approvals processes but
it just really goes to show that
sometimes the best solutions are the
simplest solutions and you know two
years ago even this project would not
have happened just because the
technology then wouldn't have supported
it but now with advanced computing and
how developed our internet is it's
really the golden era for innovation and
so the question I ask all of you today
is why wait together we can build the
future today thanks